the partial government shutdown is now
expected to run into next week with no
vote scheduled to end it one Republican
senator told CBS News there was a sense
of urgency on Capitol Hill although many
members were still away for the holidays
the House and Senate were in session for
a combined six minutes and 36 seconds
yesterday Senate Democrat leader Chuck
Schumer said in a statement that budget
negotiators are still very far apart
President Trump insists he won't let the
government reopen until Democrats agree
to spend billions of dollars for a
border wall the president's press
secretary Sarah Sanders is with us now
from the White House Sarah good morning
good morning and great to be with you
thanks for joining us a Republican
congressman mark meadows has said that
the president has made several proposals
can you give us some specifics about
what President Trump is offering in
terms of the border law look he wants
border security who wants to be able to
have the resources and the tools that
are needed that CBP and Department of
Homeland Security have laid out that
they have to have in order to protect
our border in order to protect American
citizens Democrats on the other hand who
have talked about wanting border
security who have even talked about
wanting walls and barriers and other
things all of a sudden have changed
their tune and now don't even want to
sit down at the table and negotiate with
Republicans Chuck Schumer says we're
very far apart the reason for that is
they've left the table altogether so of
course we're far apart because they're
unwilling to actually do something to
help protect our borders and and protect
American people but Sarah people are
sorry I just wanna interrupt you for a
second numbers-wise we've heard a lot of
mixed numbers that the president is
willing to come down to two billion
dollars maybe a little lower can you
give us any idea what the president will
be willing to accept financially for
border security for his border wall
where you could reach a deal if
Democrats would get there but we've made
that clear to the Democrats we're not
going to negotiate in the press but the
president has been willing to negotiate
on this point and the Democrats have not
been willing to do anything and that's
the sad part they care more about
keeping our borders open than keeping
our government open they do not want to
protect American citizens but they do
want to protect illegal immigrants and
it's a very sad day when we can't get
Democrats even show up for work and sit
down with us and have these
conversations and try to help make
real solutions and get something done
and that's exactly what we're seeing
take place over the last 24 and 48 hours
Sarah let's talk about who this shutdown
is impacting 800,000 federal workers one
of those federal workers told us that
they're living paycheck to paycheck
because they're not being paid by the
federal government and yet we have the
president tweeting that most of these
workers are Democrats earlier he tweeted
that he had communications suggesting
they're supporting him most of these
federal workers supporting him what
evidence does the president have that
they're Democrats that they're
supporting him and what message does the
White House have as these people
struggle to make it through the holidays
look nobody wants anybody to struggle
that nobody wants the government to be
closed that's why we're asking Democrats
to sit down and negotiate something they
actually support the real question here
is Nancy Pelosi is only looking to
protect her speakership and not protect
our borders and that's why she's
unwilling to negotiate with us and
unwilling to make any type of a deal and
unwilling to help do what is necessary
we have to stop illegal drugs coming in
we have to stop human traffickers and
child smuggling and the gangs that come
across our border we pick up ten known
or suspected terrorists a day coming
across our border and we have to be able
to stop this and we need Democrats to
sit down with us at the table and get
the job done Sarah this week a second
child died in the custody of Border
Patrol what is the administration doing
to improve conditions we spoke to the
Commissioner of CBP who said conditions
are not fit for children how are you
guaranteeing that children will be safe
and why did it take the death of a
second child to make major changes look
it it's absolutely a terrible tragedy
something no one wants to see which is
also why we're encouraging people not to
make this treacherous journey it is
dangerous this is one of the most
important reasons that we have to
protect our border so that we're not
incentivizing people to make this
dangerous journey and that they come
through the legal and correct process so
that we don't have these types of
instances we're doing everything we can
to make sure that when these people show
up most of them incredibly dehydrated
haven't eaten that we're giving them the
best care that we can a lot of these
individuals
children and adults are seen doctors for
the very first time in their lives and
that's through the CBP team and through
Department of Homeland Security we want
to do everything we can to protect life
but at the same time this is the exact
reason that we want people to come
through the legal process and not make
this treacherous journey a third of the
women that come through this journey are
rape or sexually assaulted and these are
horrific things that nobody wants to see
happen that's why we have to close up
loopholes that's why we have to break it
illegal and that's why Democrats need to
sit down and help us Sarah the legal
process that you're encouraging though
is is unrealistic it's taking people
years to get through the asylum process
so what are you doing quickly if you can
to haste in that process well that's
exactly one of the things the
president's been talking about is the
how broken our system is it's not just
the wall that he wants to see wants to
see the loopholes closed he wants to see
the process expedited but the asylum
thing we've been working with the
government of Mexico to help us so that
people can wait in Mexico so that this
process can be a lot more streamlined a
lot more efficient people aren't waiting
years to see judges this is something
we've asked for more judges to be
brought on so that cases can be heard
quicker and people aren't waiting such
extended periods of time but again we
need Congress to be able to fix a lot of
these problems and Democrats are
unwilling to even sit down at the table
it's a sad day in America when the
Mexican government serves architect our
borders then the Democrats are Sara
we're tight on time here we appreciate
your perspective this morning thank you
very much have a happy new year
absolutely thanks so much for having me
and Happy New Year